la tension car c'est souvent qu'elles se
propagera castaldi regardez moi
j'aimerai quand on a brassé comme toi
jusqu'à 100000 euros par mois qu'est-ce
qui a été le plus dur a lâché dont on
ancien train de vie à
spacex aimons tant et qui m'a lâché en
face à m qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'ai
raconté beaucoup de poids mais j'ai fait
j'ai fait des mauvais investissements
jean procès avec une banque les autres
etc
j'espère que ça va bien se terminer je
vais gagner aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous
avez voilà j'ai dit grosses casseroles
au cul ouais bah ouais et lui s'étaient
fa lun non le en fait ce qui est en fait
ce qui est le plus dur je vais très
honnête c'est que quand on voit qu'en
fait quand la merde arriveront ce père
soit que ça va durer qu'un temps qu'on
n'ouvre pas les yeux dans quoi pendant
un temps j'ai fait celui qui voyait pas
les meufs qui allait me tomber sur la
figure et sam est en vie depuis que j'ai
absolument tout perdu donc ce qui est ce
qui est le plus dur à lâcher de danse
ont un train de vie c'est le regard de
vos enfants qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi vous pouvez plus faire ce que
vous faisiez avant parce que le reste ce
n'est que du matériel et que finalement
voilà une bagnole ça ça se remplace
mais quand le regard de vos enfants
changent parce qu'ils ne comprennent pas
pourquoi c'est différent et pourquoi il
ya moins de cadeaux et pourquoi et
pourquoi et pourquoi et pourquoi et que
ça devient aussi pour un vrai
traumatisme parce que on leur fait des
réflexions à l'école parce qu'on leur
dis à ton père les bains dares alors
qu'ils savent très bien que c'est plus
qu'à ça c'est ce qui est plus dur dans
ce qui m'est arrivé le reste honnêtement
je vais être je vais être je vais être
franc voilà pu voir deux porsche ou
ferrari c'est pas très grave
et surtout ça peut se racheter par
contre les enfants et le mal que ça leur
a fait
vous êtes